our fundamental goal is to end extreme
poverty in the world and we just
released a report that says that if the
warming continues as it is now by 2030
an additional 100 million people will be
plunged into poverty through
difficulties with agriculture poor
health outcomes and inability to respond
to natural disasters and so this is
directly connected to our mission but
we're also at the World Bank Group we're
human beings and we see some of the
things that were just talked about on
the show we we see droughts we see
potentially 40% of the land that grows
maize and corn right now in sub-saharan
Africa being unable to do so by 2030 so
we see so many different issues that we
deal with every day energy energy
agriculture health education we see so
many things under threat because of
climate change that we have no choice
not only to act but act in a huge way we
recently pledged twenty nine billion
dollars total of spending on climate
related issues by 2020 I mean there are
people who argue that I mean let's take
some of these causes let's take extreme
weather conditions natural disasters
they say actually be cheaper and we are
getting better at dealing with natural
disasters that when we have flooding now
fewer people die wouldn't it be better
to spend the money on that rather than
slowing down the global economy oh well
we have to do both and so you know we
have to really get away from the notion
that if you tackle climate change you
will slow down the global economy you
know the key is to get the incentives
right first thing we have to do is to
get prices right there is an actual cost
to putting carbon in the air and now
there is such widespread agreement that
we need a price on carbon and this is
not just environmental activists we see
the heads of many energy companies
saying we know it's necessary we know
you got to do it let's just go ahead and
do it so you get a price on carbon if
you get the kind of then incentives in
place for low carbon solutions I think
you're going to see the development of
many new innovations and technologies
that will actually drive
growth and so we can't fall into the
trap of saying on the one hand you have
economic growth on the other hand you
have battling climate change in the
battle against climate change we both
have to mitigate meaning we have to
reduce the amount of carbon put in the
air but we also have to adapt and that's
the kind of thing that we need to do for
example in Mozambique every time there's
an extreme weather event in Mozambique
we lose we lose many many people because
the systems are not in place we have to
build those systems but at the same time
we have to reduce the amount of carbon
we're putting in the air carbon price
and indeed alternative energy sources
mean more expensive energy and that is a
cost to consumers it is a cost of
business isn't it well if you look at
something very straight forward so when
I when I joined the World Bank Group in
July of 2012
Al Gore former Vice President Al Gore
came to me was very excited that the
cost of solar had gone down as low as 15
cents in some places well today the cost
is around five or six cents so just in
the three and a half years and since
I've been in this job the cost of
installed solar has gone down by
two-thirds so I think that with with
potential expansion of solar with
expansion of wind with the exploitation
of geothermal possibilities for example
in Ethiopia there's a major project
going forward in Ethiopia less than 10
percent of the hydroelectric capacity in
sub-saharan Africa has been exploited
whereas in in the rich nations in the
OECD countries
ninety percent of hydroelectric
potential has been exploited so there's
a lot that we can do to clean up our
energy at while at the same time we
promote economic growth do you agree
with people from what used to be called
the the well was for the developing
world who say look most of this carbon
has been put there by countries like
America Europe now China they're the
ones who got to pay for the cleanup and
that it's wrong to hold back those
developing economies in their energy
consumption well you know that the
argument is is is complex but but here's
how I see it what the African countries
are saying is on the one hand
we did almost nothing to put the carbon
in the air and when extreme weather
events happens like droughts or flooding
we're impacted the most that's not fair
and this is why in Copenhagen
you know Minh when there was an
agreement the agreement also when there
was not an agreement on climate as a
whole there was an agreement that the
wealthy countries would would provide a
hundred billion a year by 2020 now we
think there's a very credible path
toward getting to that hundred billion
and we at the World Bank Group as I've
suggested a pledge that we would provide
as much as twenty nine billion so it is
it is extremely important that we do
this in a fair and just way which means
we say to the poor countries yes you
deserve energy yes you deserve to
develop yes you deserve to be able to
provide jobs and health and education to
your people but we've got to do it in a
way that is more and more decoupled from
the burning of fossil fuels we've
actually seen great examples of this
happening in many places in the world
now what we've got to do is get the
incentives right so that people that
companies all over the world for example
are saying hey you know China has
committed to a national carbon trading
program by 2017
so any company that wants to do business
in China better start thinking about
low-carbon solutions we see that
happening and as that happens I think we
can see a very bright future where
economies are growing but in a way
that's much cleaner than in the past
Kim thank you very much for joining us